I didn't think we could make another
episode but we did it a lot of these are
thanks to you guys
number one so we know that you can
shortcut to your first item quick slot
by holding down on the d-pad but did you
know that you can also shortcuts to your
first Atun spell by holding up pew s
vowel caster builds have always had it
tough with toggling between spells and
the highest skill cap thing you can do
as a caster really is quickly switch
between spells to confuse your opponents
so this gives you more control
does this make sorcery viable in PvP no
no it doesn't nothing will number two is
in the running for the most obscure
secret of Dark Souls 3 so summon an NPC
phantom called swamp kook ulis outside
of the old demon king boss fog and then
kill the old demon king with youkilis
still alive then you know have an
epiphany about how QQ 'less is obviously
corn X's apprentice and remember to
check back at core Nyx's cage in the
undead settlement a corpse will now be
there holding corn X's amazing pyromancy
set and the spotted whip which poisons
foes if you found this naturally in your
playthrough well done this isn't all you
can get from summoning NPCs though if
Knights layered Sorek kills you and be
honest I mean he killed everyone right
you get them my thanks emote if you
summon the LAN door pale shade you get
the dual bow if you summon black
handguard you get by my sword and yellow
finger gives you the proper power I'm
quite sure that there's others that I'm
missing and maybe even some that no one
has discovered yet I don't know if you
find any let everyone know number 3 New
Game+ is disappointing in this game
enemy damage doesn't seem to scale too
much and I personally haven't noticed
any new enemy placements which at least
Dark Souls 2 did right at any rate new
game +1 and new game+ to grant access to
some of the +1 +2 and +3 rings some of
the best ones are the +2 gold serpent
ring or
the +2 ring of favor I'll leave a list
to them all in the description if you
want to hunt them down number 4 so in
the last episode I was really surprised
to hear that so many of you got stuck in
a hollowing state without a way to cure
it I just realized that sounds like a
making fun of you but it really is
really hard to cure hollowing if you
don't know how so if you don't have
access to purging stones because urea
has gone then just go to the Statue of
velka after purchasing the grave key and
you can request disillusion there once
you've done this and healed the dark
sigil at the fire keeper then you know
all those hours spent in the character
creator they were no longer for nothing
number 5 the hollow gem infusion allows
a weapon to scale with your luck stat
which I'm discovering is awesome if you
run a poison or bleed build since those
things scale with luck as well in
addition though did you know that
actually being hollow while also having
a hollow infusion gives you a +5 bonus
to your luck stat so if you're running a
luck build just infuse your shield with
hollowing and even if it's on your back
you're still reaping the benefits it's a
neat little mechanic to make luck that
tiny bit more viable
speaking of infusions the simple
infusion also has a hidden benefit it
scales with intelligence but it also
restores focus at a rate of about one
focus point per 4 seconds now that
sounds horrible but it is actually
amazing for some weapons that can take
advantage of it take the sunlight
straight sword for example if I have
zero focus points then I can't cast the
buff but if I have even one focus point
then I can so if you're using a weapon
that benefits greatly from even a tiny
amount of focus and most do then throw
this infusion on an offhand shield or
something it's amazing number seven is
to do with consuming Souls if you have a
ton that you want to consume then the
fastest way is just to sell them at the
handmaiden she gives you the same amount
that you'd usually get number eight when
you're deciding whether to make that
risky jump because there's a shiny over
there
consider this important items like estes
shards or weapons or rings they have a
large glow whereas regular items like
consumables have a small glow so if you
have to choose between two items and a
giant's about to smack the [ __ ] out of
you then make sure you choose the right
one number 9 segue so if you like me
right now and you have a huge pile of
souls that you need to get back to then
never fear because here's a mechanic I
only learned about recently the ring of
sacrifice makes it so that you don't
lose souls upon death which everybody
knows but did you also know that it
gives you another chance to recover any
lost souls already waiting for you in
the world so here you can see my souls
over there I'm going to recover them but
I die on my way but since I have the
ring of sacrifice equipped the pile of
souls remains and I have another chance
to recover them so props to Superman
drew 7 for making me aware of this one
number 10 the giant tree by your shrine
it sometimes leaves a seed of a giant
tree behind which can be used to
temporarily seed your world any invader
into a seeded world will not only have
to deal with the host they also have to
deal with the normal enemies in that
world which just you know pushes the
odds more into the hosts favor I really
don't get what from has against invaders
anyway
the trigger for a seed to drop appears
to be really similar to what it was in
Dark Souls 2 where simply being invaded
can give you a chance to receive a seed
for me I found it was about a 50% chance
that the seed would appear after I was
invaded but my sample size was pretty
small so it's hard to say the exact
percent in Dark Souls 2 it was 25% I
believe regardless if you do get invaded
then remember to check for a seed
because you can hold up to five at a
time
but only one can be at the tree at any
one time number 11 if you want to be
invaded more often and who doesn't use a
dried finger from the handmaiden using
it resets your invasion timer which is
nothing new but what is new is that it
allows you to summon a third friendly
phantom and a second invading phantom a
hidden thing is that
to remove this effect you have to travel
to a new bonfire not just rest at one
when you get grabbed by the rocks tre
diamond did you know that you can mash
the shoulder buttons and the face
buttons to escape its grab of course you
did you're a Souls veteran and you
probably do mash a lot of buttons out of
reflex but in this game the only grab
attack I've managed to escape from is
this one mashing is no use against
mimics the Gru's other bosses seem to
have a set animation I guess
the rule is that if there's an enemy
that sort of crushes you and you can see
your character wriggle in response to
your button presses then that is when
you mash the buttons 13 the messaging
system no longer requires an orange
soapstone and it's available here in
your options menu and at first glance
the messaging system looks terrible
but that's only until you press the
triangle button and all of a sudden
you'll have access to conjugations
another extension of your message and
even gestures as well which returns from
blood-borne no skeleton ahead and then
skeleton perfect if a player rates that
message positive or negative then I'll
receive a health boost at that moment
but it is funny that it rewards you for
placing a terrible or evil message as
well number 14 is a returning mechanic
from Dark Souls 1 it's that there's an
easy way to deal with mimics and there
are a shitload of mimics in this game of
course you all know that you can tell if
it's a mimic if the chain on the side is
straight and if the chest itself is very
lightly breathing just like in Dark
Souls 1 as well though Lloyds talismans
put mimics to sleep
while asleep they'll allow you to pick
up the item it usually drops so you can
continue on your way after that if
you're lucky though it'll drop the
symbol of avarice which is a helmet that
helps you get more item discovery which
is great in this game the best way to
farm this is actually just to pegged
Lloyds talismans at it until it drops it
throw a talisman hit the mimic to wake
it up and then throw another talisman
until you get it or until you run out of
Lloyds talismans you get more Lloyds
talismans from the hand maiden after
picking up the paladin's ashes kudos to
Patara on reddit for reminding me that
Lloyds talismans are a thing all right
so this last thing isn't just a
discovery it's also a bit of a call to
action which I haven't done very often
so I'm interested to see how well this
can work so I can't quite figure out
this mechanic as you played through Dark
Souls 3 I'm sure you notice that you
randomly get an extra Estus sometimes
when you kill an enemy right sometimes
you even get two flasks myself and
illusory wall who is a Dark Souls wizard
we set out to figure out exactly what
triggers this to happen sometimes and so
far all we've discovered is that certain
enemies have a higher chance to give you
flasks than others enemies like
darkwraiths for example they always give
you two and red eye skeletons etc the
odd thing is though even these enemies
stopped giving us flasks after a little
while and a similar mechanic existed in
Dark Souls 1 with humanity enemies had a
hidden point system associated with them
which upon death would count towards you
eventually receiving a humanity
guaranteed and I have a theory that Dark
Souls 3 does work similar to this but I
also have a faint hope that the chance
of you getting estes could be associated
with the luck stat I think that would be
really cool but that's just because I
want luck to be accepted as a worthy
stat so if you want to help us figure
out this mechanic then get out there
drain and Estus flask and record what
types of enemies you have to kill before
you received a flask my hope is that
with a bit more raw data in the comment
section then we might get a little bit
closer because the only thing that's
confusing
is that it's irregular after a certain
point and if you do this then make sure
you throw your luck stat in the comments
as well maybe this is the thing thanks
for watching guys um I know this isn't
the most interesting video I could have
done there are so many amazing videos I
want to make and thing is I've actually
commissioned those pieces of art upon
the game coming out and the art is still
coming in and it just so happened this
was the first video that had its art
ready and if you don't know I spend like
hundreds of dollars every single video
just on the art itself which is
available for patrons as well if you
want to get that as a wallpaper and
that's just a way of rewarding people
for being able to fund like the
incredible artwork that I love to
commissioned which I'm incredibly
grateful for didn't mean to go on a
tangent about patrons and such but yeah
thanks for watching
regardless and I will see you in the
next one and the next one it's going to
be a very good video bye guys